I'll just say as I have for a while that  I still think the time is very strong I  know there's some disagreements but I  think as the numbers shakeout Commerce  Department is reopening or gonna get a  GDP report probably next week we'll get  a jobs report this Friday so that'll  work out based on things we've talked  about here unemployment claims low  industrial production strong business  investment strong holiday sales very  strong I still think we're on a 3%  trendline growth rate I'm proud of that  I think that the program of lower tax  rates and regulatory rollback and  opening up energy and so forth as happen  is working and is continuing to work and  I think frankly the optimist the guys  that took the over are going to be right  because maybe